okay hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
um
i'm
sorry to miss last week but i'm back
this week and happy to
try and take um
whatever questions i can about uh any
topics in science and technology we have
a number of questions that got asked
from our
form and other things there's a question
from eli
about thoughts on longevity research and
feasibility
and um
a variety of comments about that
so
uh let's talk a little bit about how
long things live
you know in
one feature of of us humans
is
we tend to live you know uh on on
average 80 something years whatever it
is in the us it's different amounts of
time in different countries different
situations um but
one feature is
that if you look at
the chance that we die in each
successive year it goes up dramatically
as we get older we talk about why that
happens but that's not true of all
species
there are some species where
including some plants for example where
the probability of dying actually goes
down as you get older that doesn't mean
you live forever
but it means that if you're a certain
kind of tree you know maybe a redwood
tree i'm not sure about that
um
there could be things that are kind of
wrong with the redwood tree that will
cause it to die in its first few years a
couple year two years whatever but if
you make it out of that period you're
probably a redwood tree that has sort of
everything more or less set up right
and then you can keep going for a
thousand years
and you'll just keep sort of uh and
nothing will go too badly wrong
now they're also
uh what is it the um
naked mole rat i believe
uh is an example of a
an organism
that again an animal
uh even a mammal that has this feature
that
its probability
the probability that it dies in a given
year
stays i think constant
throughout its life so if if the
probability of dying in a given year is
constant
it still means that eventually
the the
the let's say there's a one percent
chance
of dying each year that means that there
will be on average
it will be it will live 100 years
but it means that there is a if you look
at uh let's say a thousand different
individuals it means there will be some
that have this sort of tale of living
much longer than that because they
happen to
you know every year it's like you flip a
coin
and there's a 99 chance of surviving a
one percent chance of dying
and if you keep flipping the coin
in the
living side each year you can just keep
going forever so to speak
so
the question for for us humans
is okay that's kind of a bad feature
that the probability of dying seems to
increase
actually exponentially kind of the
probability goes up uh
um
uh every
the probability of dying of some cause
goes up it kind of multiplies by some
factor every year i think that stops
being the case if you make it past 100
or so
then the probability actually goes down
a bit
and that is it doesn't it doesn't keep
going up
um
uh at that point
so
what
why does this happen well
it's not really totally clear
what causes aging in general
and
some people think that aging is just
something that's built into us as
biological organisms
as
a feature of something that is kind of
intended for the benefit of the whole
species i mean the basic thing is
if
if kind of the the all the individuals
of the species lived for a really long
time you'd have all these cumulative
characters who said you know
when i was young 200 years ago this is
how things worked and the world should
never change and um
uh
you know
all these resources that might be used
by the eager young critters the eager
young humans um would be being used up
by the the 200 300 year old humans now
as a as an old human myself
it seems like it would seem like a much
a good deal
if um
uh the us humans could kind of uh live
indefinitely long but in biological
evolution it could be the case that
perhaps there was a um
uh
that perhaps in the past there was the
possibility of living much longer um
that was selected against because it
actually was bad for the species to have
everybody just kind of hang around so to
speak
now
the actual mechanics of what causes
aging i think i've talked about this a
different time as well um there are a
variety of different theories about what
mechanically causes aging
and to what extent uh there are a
variety of different kinds of things for
example
our
uh
as as we get
we're continually producing new cells
and every new cell we produce has to
kind of re-run the program from the dna
to produce proteins and to make the
structure of the cell
and there is progressive buildup perhaps
of errors in that dna or other kinds of
problems with the dna
that mean that as we go on and we live
longer and we've replicated cells more
and more often
that the chance that we have a bad
program so to speak to represent the new
cells goes up
so one of the things that's sort of
implicated in that is at the at the ends
so we have 23 chromosomes and um
the at the ends of those chromosomes
there are uh end caps to kind of keep
the two strands of dna dna is this
double-stranded molecule
that has the sequence of of essentially
bits that represent how one should be
elements that one should assemble for
the proteins that are the molecules that
we use
um and
the whenever we make one of these
proteins we read a little section of the
dna that section might be
uh a thousand base pairs long it might
be a few million base pairs long we're
kind of transcribing that piece of code
to actually make the uh the structure of
the protein out of a sequence of amino
acid units that are sort of uh assembled
together in a line to make the protein
okay so on the chromosomes
there are end caps on the chromosomes
that stop the strands of dna from kind
of coming apart they're called telomeres
and they are repeated sequences of uh i
forget what they are att something i
forget what what the actual sequence is
but it's a it's a progressively repeated
sequence maybe repeated 50 times or some
such other thing
and every time
cells replicate maybe
on average we lose one element of that
end cap
and so eventually we've lost all of them
and then the chromosomes can't sort of
maintain their stability and start
peeling apart that was kind of a theory
from a while ago of what might be sort
of a core feature of aging
it's
not quite as simple as that because
there are enzymes chemicals that can
actually add those end caps to the end
of the dna and so it makes it um
it makes it um
uh
and when we like exercise and do good
things to ourselves that enzyme
potentially is active and potentially
adds elements to the ends of the dna so
it isn't really the case that every time
the dna replicates it loses one of those
end caps so that theory isn't quite
right another theory which has been i
think
is is
there's
this sort of increasing interest in
is about methylation of dna
so
in standard dna
there are
these
different units these different bases
each base is a is a clump of a few tons
of atoms
and there are ones that
a t c and g are the letters that are the
kind of acronyms for the names of the
the chemicals that correspond to those
bases
and
uh what when we make up a dna molecule
we are having a sequence of those units
all glued together okay so there's this
process called methylation
that is a modification to those bases
and i think for a couple of those bases
more common to happen than for the
others
and that process adds some atoms
rearranges some atoms in that base the
fundamental
structure of the base is still the same
but it's had some modification made to
it
and
in um
uh the thing that
that those modifications
seem to be important
in determining for example uh which
genes will be activated
and
and kind of and how that will work
and that
process of methylation
does get passed down as you replicate
the dna
so in other words once
a particular dna in a particular cell
has been methylated in some way then the
cells which are produced by division of
that cell will get this effect
and people say
it's
uh that that is important both in how
whether a particular so all the cells in
our body that whatever it is 100
trillion or so cells in our bodies um
they all have the same basic underlying
dna code
but different cells turn into different
things they might turn into a hair cell
or a kidney cell or heart cell um and
the specification of
it does that by reading a different part
of the dna program and producing
different proteins from that but the
specification of what it should read may
very well be somewhat related to this
this methylation idea of attaching these
extra pieces to bases in the in the
dna sequence
and so things can go wrong
those sort of methylations can be
attached too much too little
and
it's
uh somewhat it seems to be the case that
that's at least correlated with the
emergence of cancers
in in our cells and and essentially what
ultimately what tumors are
is unconstrained growth of cells
normally when we grow
it's not true for all kinds of all kinds
of animals and plants
when we grow
we only want to grow to a certain size
and then we stop we get you know at some
age in our late teens or whatever we
stop growing if we were redwood trees we
would just keep growing keep growing
keep growing or sometimes a fish just
keep growing all of their lives and they
keep adding more tissue they keep
getting their bones keep on getting
longer if they're for things like fish
whatever else but we don't do that
and so that means that that if
something but when what can happen is
that a tumor which is sort of a more
primitive form of life that doesn't
have this risk this restraint that
causes it to stop growing when it gets
to sort of full size
if we get something which is a tumor it
will just keep going and keep going and
that's really bad because eventually it
will kind of take over resources that we
need and start strangling kind of organs
that are important to us and things like
this
so the question is how does that come to
happen
and uh quite possibly
i mean in the end when you look at
tumors
they tend to have really messed up
genetics
so you know you have the ordinary dna
sequence and we have the ordinary number
of chromosomes but often if you take a
tumor cell and you look at what is its
genetics it'll be all messed up it'll
have the wrong number of chromosomes
it'll have all kinds of modifications to
genes things like this
uh it also will have a complicated and
different pattern of methylation
different from the one that's seen in
ordinary cells
and actually there's some new tests that
exist for sort of detecting the
emergence of of cancer anywhere in the
body so called liquid biopsies where you
just take a blood sample and then you
measure
the methylation of the dna of a bunch of
cells and then you see whether that
pattern uh agrees with what you would
expect from ordinary tissue or whether
it's something bad and weird
so but the emergence of how does sort of
cancer take hold and that's one of the
things that causes us to to die um and
uh you know how does that take hold um
what causes that to happen as we get
older not really known
the
thing that is pretty likely is that our
immune system
will recognize when there's a cancer
cell and zap it
and even if a little you know a few
cells go haywire that our immune system
will be able to kill those off just as
it can kill off bacteria or cells
infected with viruses that we get
the reason it's difficult for the immune
system to zap cancer cells is because
the immune system is usually operating
looking for cells
or other proteins
that are not things that are part of us
in our kind of
well in our in our younger years before
about teenage
time
our immune system is being kind of
trained
to notice
which which
which proteins which
uh sequences of base pairs and so on
are
things which are
uh which are which are us sequences so
for example there are six billion base
pairs in the whole human genome and if
you look at i don't know a sequence of i
don't know 15 of those base pairs
even at that level
it's possible to tell is this a sequence
of 15 base pairs that could be part of
me or is it something that no that isn't
a possible length 15 sequence that's
part of me that's part of my six billion
base pair sequence
um but would have to be some foreign
thing a virus or or some other kind of
thing
and so we learned that
in our early life so to speak we learn
to distinguish self from non-self when
it comes to these base pair sequences
and so on
and so the thing that happens with with
cancer for example is that there's an
evasion of that um
of that mechanism because the cancer
cells really have the same fundamental
dna that we do they've just been
modified in some way um but in a way
that doesn't uh that potentially evades
the immune system now i mentioned that
the cancer cells do change their
genetics so that kind of suggests that
there is a way to recognize that
and to have the immune system respond to
them
but it's not really known i think
what causes our built-in immune system
to not be able to successfully mount an
attack on things like tumor cells
actually the messenger rna
technology that was used for the
vaccines for for covid um that was had
been being developed for quite a while
for the purpose of making kind of custom
vaccines
which would uh sort of enhance the
immune system
when tumors appeared in people so the
idea would be you kind of sequence the
tumor you get to find the base pair
sequence the dna for the tumor and you
say you figure out oh this is the thing
which if only the immune system knew to
attack that it would get rid of this and
it will be good and so the idea was to
kind of be able to create these sort of
custom vaccines that would attack tumor
cells and no doubt after this
perhaps some
well let's just say the huge public
health experiment of vaccinating a
billion people um with or whatever it is
now um with these mrna vaccines
now that we kind of know what happens
when you do that
it seems
it's something which one can make use of
the same technology to do things with
for example uh tumors and that's that's
kind of interesting
but in general the question i mentioned
that the probability of dying for humans
increases exponentially with age roughly
um up to age 100 and something
um and the longest
humans have been recorded to live is
about 125 years
um
and there's sort of the question of of
how that will
develop over time
and whether that lifespan can be
extended and if so how
and i think one thing if you look at
the uh life expectancy
uh it's always a you have to say life
expectancy at what age it's like the
time when you're born
there are all sorts of things that can
go wrong in the first year of life
there are all kinds of genetic mistakes
that can exist and things like that that
will be bad news in the first year of
life if you make it through that make it
through the first few years then the
probability of dying in a given year
goes i think it's a minimum um in the
maybe late teens early 20s things like
that humans us humans are pretty robust
at those ages and then it starts starts
going up
but uh the the question of life
expectancy you have to decide how old
were you when you asked what was the
average number of years that you were
going to live so there's life expectancy
at birth there's life expectancy at age
10 for example the life expectancy at
age 10 is larger than the life
expectancy of birth because at birth
there's some chance that there will be
something horribly wrong which will not
let you live
beyond age you know one or two or
whatever um
so
in any case the the life expectancy at
birth
for in many countries like the us has
been progressively growing
for for a long time for 50 years maybe
or more
and in fact so if you look at the curve
i haven't looked at in the last couple
of years but i don't think it will be
much affected by by things that have
been going on
the um the life expectancy is going up
by about one-third of the year per year
so uh between you know 1960 and now
um the life expectancy has gone up by
let's say um you know well that would
suggest if it's one-third of a year per
year that would be 20 years i'm not sure
if that's quite right but i think that
sounds sounds about right
and one question is well why is that
happened
and i think the number one reason is
because particular diseases that killed
people have been
much
if not solved they've been greatly uh
reduced in
importance and most important one is
cardiovascular heart diseases of various
kinds
all sorts of uh heart surgery and and
heart enhancement and pacemakers and all
this kind of thing things which help the
heart just keep on beating and and uh
supplying blood in the right way
those things
have become much better over the years
and much more is known about them much
more is known about what kinds of things
are risks
for heart disease and so on there's much
more known about being able to uh do
imaging whether it's with
various kinds of x-ray imaging or mri
or um
ultrasound and so on that tell you
whether there's something wrong and
whether you need to fix it
but in general
the
it is uh it's you know if we say well
how are you going to extend sort of
human lifespan
um
the you know one thing that's the case
is that many different kinds of things
that can go wrong there are
maybe a hundred thousand diseases that
have been catalogued and they're not all
completely distinct but and not all of
them can kill you so to speak uh
but you know there's sort of the
question of of how do you how do you
sort of fix each individual one of these
things and let's say you fix the big
ones the most important ones that will
have an effect for example uh you know
fixing a lot of stuff to do with heart
disease
you're still left with things to do with
cancer and so on as a quite separate uh
branch that you then have to go and fix
and so there's sort of a question of can
you extend the human lifespan
by just going in and fixing individual
diseases and the answer is yes you can
get a long way and that's why the life
expectancy has been going up in the past
50 years or so
as a result of fixing particular kinds
of diseases
now you know there will probably always
be a very long tale of things that can
go wrong we kind of have learnt that
from looking at a quite different kind
of system which is software where
software like us humans is a very
complicated can be a very complicated
system many different subsystems and
many different pieces and so on and we
can ask the question can we have we
found all the bugs in that piece of
software and the answer will typically
be no we haven't but many of those bugs
just aren't very important and aren't
bugs that will cause the software to
crash so to speak very often and so
that's sort of the same thing with
humans now there are different kinds of
more systemic
sorts of things which uh
make for
sort of
make humans live longer they've been a
variety of experiments that have been
done
on uh a variety of tiny tiny critters
um that look at different kinds of uh
biochemical pathways different kinds of
of processes that go on
in those creatures there's one to do
with the um
to do with insulin processing and the
cert
family of genes and proteins um
these have to do with
the way that
uh metabolism works the way that energy
um the way that we produce energy when
we eat food
we have glucose comes from the food we
kind of burn the glucose
to make energy and that's what causes us
to be able to sort of bounce around and
do all the things we do
and there are some pathways associated
with that and associated with some of
the some of the chemicals like insulin
that are used as part of that metabolism
process
and there's some evidence that changing
those pathways
will extend lifespan and i think that's
been done
i think maybe has been done with rats by
now i'm not sure i'm not sure up to what
level i mean the original creatures for
which this was found were tiny little
worm-like creatures um
and uh whether those kinds of
discoveries extend to higher organisms
not clear because as i mentioned there
are organisms where their sort of
longevity profile is completely
different from from things like humans
so there's this kind of idea that
by modifying these genes one could
increase lifespan it's not completely
known why that would increase lifespan
but it's something that has empirically
been seen at least for some lower
organisms
now there are all kinds of sort of
theories that come up about sort of
what increased his lifespan i mean one
popular one was uh caloric restriction
just eat less
i think the evidence on that is not
terribly strong um i think that at
various times people have said oh yeah
that's really going to make people live
longer i don't think there's great
evidence for that um and the the more
detailed experiments have been
uh i think not not very convincing and
they're also
one of the sort of downsides is it could
be well yes
you can be a critter that
uh sort of eats less does less is kind
of in a semi-hibernating state all the
time you could say well yes i can live
longer but i'm going to be like like a
like a cold-blooded
animal
not in you know in the cold when the
animal just sort of grinds to a halt
and um and and does very little i mean
when it's basically hibernating so if
you want to be a hibernating human uh
that might be one path and you might
live longer but in hibernation
effectively which probably isn't such a
such a big win
but there are a variety of these ideas
that come up
with some frequency of sort of these
biochemical pathways that might be
kind of the things that are just overall
clocks for us humans that just sort of
say as a result of the way that we've
evolved oh you should uh you know don't
live too long it's bad for the species
type thing and if we could switch off
those clocks
and have us be able to be uh you know
energetic
for longer well it will be certainly a
win for the individual i think some of
those clocks are associated with the
immune system and with the fact that
uh potentially our immune system gets
weaker and weaker as we get older
whether that's always the case or not
it's just not known
um and i think the general you know it's
it's kind of funny because people come
up with all these elaborate medical
ideas about sort of how to get greater
longevity and and some of them are are
significant but an awful lot of them
come down to
uh sort of lead a healthy life type
thing um you know eat sensibly exercise
sleep enough these kinds of things
i think one which has actually been
somewhat neglected
in
uh for some time is the sleep enough
type kind of idea um and it's turning
out that all kinds of of terrible
maladies can occur if you uh if you're
uh
you know if you're always short of sleep
so to speak
so i mean those are it's
the state of research on kind of
longevity and aging
sort of interesting because
there are fields of science where people
just say oh that's not a worthwhile
thing to study and 30 years ago that's
what people were typically saying about
aging and longevity it's like you'll
never figure out anything it's not worth
studying
now there's increasing interest and
increasing amounts of effort being put
into doing that
one of the really weird problems
particularly in the u.s system
is if you make a drug
some medical intervention of some kind
then the question is how does that get
when if somebody wants to get that drug
who pays for that
and in the us particularly
there's this idea of medical insurance
and much of the time
things are not being paid directly by
the person who's getting that medicine
they're being paid by some insurance
company or some other a whole sort of
system that's dealing with that
and the problem is that that whole
system is set up to say if you're sick
will pay for you to be made better
and that means that that what that
actually turns into is every different
disease has an icd code international
classification diseases i think that
stands for icd-9 or icd-10 code it's
this big directory of all these
different diseases and every disease
gets one of those
and so you can say oh i've got this
disease it's icd code such and such
and then the medical insurance company
will say okay we pay x amount for fixing
that disease okay that's all good the
problem is
nobody thinks that aging as such is a
disease
it's not some misfortune that happens
it's something that happens to everybody
and so it's been a sort of a
long-running issue that there's no
code
for aging there's nothing that says
that's a disease and medical insurance
will pay to get it fixed
so that's been that bizarre little
bureaucratic wrinkle has been something
that has slowed down research in this
area quite a bit
but one sort of hopes that uh i don't
know for me as a as a an increasingly
ancient person i kind of uh hope that
that
kind of research is
is done as quickly as possible
but um
you know what will it really look like i
think
that
there are likely to be some sort of
molecular scale things
that are particularly enhancing the
immune system i think the immune system
is the big kind of fixer of things in
our bodies
in general
and
for example
things that go wrong include cells that
have just become too old and you know
the immune system should clean those
cells out but it's not clear that's
really happening when one gets older
one's immune system may have a less
aggressive point of view about what kind
of cells should be cleaned out
and so quite a lot of sort of what one
one might look at has to do with
enhancing the immune system and so on
but there are other kinds of things
let's say fixing particular organs that
break
being able to make artificial organs
and that's something that increasingly
seems likely that it's possible to make
artificial organs there are a lot of
weird things that happen
in us
and that
are kind of hard to
uh to deal with for for
example well
let's say that you know your heart
muscle
is failing in some way
you might say well how are you going to
fix that oh you've got to put in more
heart muscle but actually there's some
evidence that if you start off with
cells that were like the cells that from
which
we all started growing the single cell
from that
we start replicating from
a so-called stem cell
or a pluripotent stem cell a stem cell
that has many potentialities for what it
will become
that if you take one of those cells and
you just generally put it in the
direction of the of the heart
that what will happen is that it will go
there and it will suddenly say oh i'm in
you know i'm
you know put in the in the area where
there's heart muscle i should be a heart
muscle cell and it will then become a
heart muscle cell
and and potentially supplement the cells
that were already there so there are a
bunch of kinds of ideas like that which
kind of on the face of it sound like
they couldn't possibly work
but it seems like there's a likelihood
that they will work for reasons that
i don't think we fully understand from a
biology point of view but so that's
that's kind of a um uh the way that
those things might work is you know they
can have oh let's replace this organ
with something that is an engineered
thing an artificial whatever it is um
different organs we know how to make
artificial versions of those in some
cases we don't need to make a whole
artificial organ because the whole
purpose of the organ is to produce some
particular chemical and we can just eat
a pill that is that chemical once a day
and it will serve the same function as
that particular
organ in some cases more complicated
where you have to produce the chemical
in response to something that's going on
in the body then it's more complicated
and it requires medical devices and
things like that rather than just eat a
pill once a day kind of thing
but um you know there's some organs
where that clearly isn't what's
happening and where there's a sort of
ongoing need for the function of that
organ whether it's the heart pumping
blood or the kidneys clearing gunk out
of the blood and so on um and
so there's sort of the question of of
can one make engineered versions of
these things and first question is can
we make them be engineered to work in
the first place and the second question
is can one set them up to be engineered
and installable in the body in a way
that can be connected to all the systems
that are already there and so for
example for for hearts for instance you
would think well it's just a pump you
should be able to pump blood
but it's much harder than you think
because blood has this feature that is
sort of a good feature generally for us
which is that it coagulates it forms
clots
and so if blood stops flowing it will
start um it'll start to make this kind
of fibrous uh
connection between cells and eventually
that will turn into a blood clot and you
know if we've cut ourselves for example
the blood will stop flowing and it will
form this um uh this clot which will
eventually allow the the skin and other
things to regenerate
but um uh the problem is that if ever
the blood flow slows down somewhere it
will tend to clot
and if you're making sort of a pump-like
heart
um it's very non-trivial thing to
arrange that there's always enough flow
of blood that nothing like that happens
there's no point where the thing sort of
comes to a halt stagnates and can start
to form a clot so that it's a tricky
thing
to uh uh to build things that sort of
fit into our bodies
my guess is that it will be a lot easier
when we understand how to do things at a
molecular scale
some of the new kinds of uh the things
where
sort of the the general spectrum of
things one could do one is you have a
device
like you know pump that's pumping
something and you have it either
external to your body and it's just
pumping things through some catheter or
it's or it's something actually um
installed so to speak in the body that's
one level kind of at the other end is
drugs
where one's dealing with a particular
drug molecule that has a particular
shape and attaches to molecules that are
part of us like proteins for example
and causes those proteins to be able to
function better or or blocks their
function or whatever else but it's doing
that at a molecular scale there's kind
of an intermediate form
of medical intervention which is at the
level of things the size of little cells
for example
and and for example these vaccines that
that have just been used they have these
lipid nanoparticles which are kind of
like microscopic cells that are being
used to deliver uh to to get actually
they get
ingested inside our cells uh to then
deliver this this rna
vaccine
but there are other kinds of things
where you can have a cell that
sort of
has a special purpose cell that is not
a cell just like the ones we have but an
engineered cell-like thing that can then
get used to uh to have medical effects
so those are a few kinds of approaches
um i think um
well as the eli who asked this question
asks some
um
about computational irreducibility and
um the difficulty of solving problems
for biology i you know our experience
with programming programs and the fact
you never know if you've got all the
bugs
that's not just a practical human
limitation that's a theoretical
limitation and it's also probably a
theoretical limitation on living systems
that if you want a living system to be
kind of multifunctional to be able to do
all the kinds of different things that
living systems can do that it's of an
inevitable feature of having a system
that has that sort of multi-functional
character that it is also uh it will
have an infinite tale of possible bugs
and it will be impossible to sort of go
down and fix every one of those bugs so
that in a sense perhaps and i don't know
if this is really the case but it's
something one might imagine
that
uh the you know if the if the almost
definition of life is something to do
with being very multifunctional and
being able to sort of lock into sort of
the sophisticated computations that can
be done that an inevitable consequence
of that
is that it must be that you won't be
able to fix all the bugs
and have the thing live forever so to
speak i don't know if that's the case
but it's a plausible possibility
depending on what we really mean by by
life and what we and what happens with
sort of this this computational aspect
of it
um
the um the question
of uh
um
would it be better for lifespans to be
longer i certainly think so um i think
that it is the case that as there's more
to learn in the world
um
that uh
that kind of the more time one has to
learn that stuff
um and then make use of what one's
learned the better off i mean in other
words if if it was the case that you
could learn everything you needed to
learn by the time you're 12 years old
then um in a sense you get to have you
know if the life expectancy is 40 at
least you get to have
uh you know
um
close to 30 years to make use of the
things you've learned but if it takes
until the age of 30 for you to learn the
stuff you need to learn or even longer
than that
then you kind of have to extend the
lifespan to even be able to make use of
that or people are spending their whole
lives just learning things uh without
being able to do anything with what
they've learned
but you know i think that the um uh it's
it's unclear you know eventually i am
quite certain that effective human
immortality will be achieved i'm quite
certain that eventually we will
understand enough about molecular
biology
enough about the way that biology works
in general that it will be possible to
do that and what will happen is
typically uh you know one of the things
that happens in general in making things
work better
is to know
what's going on in the thing so that you
know what there is to fix there are two
big examples in in kind of technological
history that come to mind one is
airplanes and the other is general
anesthesia
so with airplanes used to be the case
that
it was
that you know
a decent fraction of the time there
would be plane crashes being reported
plane crashes have become very rare you
know one in millions of flights
um and why is that
the number one reason is that pilots and
people maintaining planes just know more
about what the state of a plane is you
know is there a crack somewhere in the
in the metal of the wings
is there something that went wrong when
the plane took off that should cause one
to just go back around and land at the
same airport again rather than going
across the atlantic or something um
these are things where there is
increasing the sensors and measuring
devices are getting progressively better
it's becoming progressively easier to
know what the state of the plane is so
to speak and therefore to not try flying
the plane when something is horribly
wrong with it
um whereas in the past when we're sort
of blind to those things it's like you
don't know there's something wrong until
it bites you kind of thing
i think the same thing is true of of
medical things like general anesthesia
where again it's kind of like
uh if you could monitor all these things
about you know is the
patient's blood pressure doing this or
or that or the other um you know if you
can monitor those things if you know
something was wrong is wrong it's
probably not so hard to fix it but if
you don't know it's wrong until
something terrible happens um then you
can't fix it and i believe those are two
examples where the reliability has
dramatically increased over the course
of many decades
and so one wonders about the same kind
of thing with medicine and i tend to
think this is the case that the more one
can measure the more one can kind of uh
um have uh be able to do the right thing
to avoid for example things getting much
worse so for example uh often in
medicine
um you kind of don't know something is
wrong
until your body really until something
starts to hurt or you or you have some
obvious symptom but yet something was
developing that was wrong and that could
have been detected by some method that
was not
uh something where you had to
feel it so to speak where it's some
device
some test
that's detecting these things without it
relying on kind of your brain to have it
sort of built in system that detects oh
there's pain uh which pain is kind of a
sign it's kind of the error condition
for us humans it's saying there's
something wrong and and you know
something is telling your brain that
there's something wrong and and
sometimes if it's
if there's sort of chronic pain where
it's like well i know there's something
wrong you don't need to keep on telling
me that
um that's a difficult thing that in a
sense ultimately if you kind of convince
your brain to just stop giving you that
alert all the time it would probably be
better for you
but in any case the um
i tend to think that one of the things
which is
going to and has led to sort of the the
greatest increase of sort of medical
performance will tend to be just
earlier detection and more measurement
of things and there are some sort of
thresholds in that for example i
mentioned kind of liquid biopsies
and kind of one's blood has an awful lot
of information about what's going on in
one one of the things about about us
humans is that
all sorts of fluids like blood and
saliva and things like this
there are all these cells and all these
things that just gets dumped into them
and so you know for example
in the case of oh i don't know the you
know the fact that it's possible to do a
covered test by just you know uh
scraping a little bit of
a little swab against you know the
inside of your nose it's like well it
could be the case that you know there's
covered
viruses somewhere in your body but it
doesn't kind of get out and get exposed
in that way but one thing that's very
convenient for medical purposes is that
a lot of a lot of things that go wrong
um that so there's enough mixing of
different cells and so on in the body
that
you kind of can see a trace of those
things for example in the blood
um and so
uh one of the things that's been uh i
don't know how many um
you know there are
millions of different kinds of
of chemicals and molecules and all this
kind of thing in our blood
and
when you if you kind of pick them up and
can detect them and measure them that
gives you huge amounts of information
about what's going on inside the body
one of the things that's been kind of a
long time
uh world goal i mean you know you can go
and get a blood test and somebody will
stick a needle in your arm and pull out
some blood and then
start send it to some machine and then
the machine there are a variety of
different methods for measuring uh
levels of different chemicals in your
blood um many of them are so-called
assays that will try and see for example
um if you take out uh the molecules in
your blood to those molecules uh how
well do they stick to
some particular thing that's been
constructed which is very sticky for
molecules with exactly this form and not
sticky for other molecules that's one
type of approach to figuring out whether
there is that kind of molecule and how
much of it there is in your blood some
other kinds of things like i don't know
if you just want to know how many red
blood cells how many white blood cells
do you have in a particular volume of
blood you're literally there there's
devices that just use essentially vision
systems to literally count the number of
cells of different types
and what shapes they are and all those
kinds of things but any case the that's
kind of you you pull out some blood and
you send it off to a machine and you do
these things but a kind of long-term
goal
is to have something where you can just
you know have it in your in your wrist
watch or something you have a sensor
that's just telling you what's in your
blood
now right now
many people have uh you know some such
sensors um a typical you know exercise
watch or something kind eyewear you can
um
it's it has a little sensor it has that
green flashing thing underneath
that green flashing thing is flashing
essentially laser light
into what's it's an led actually it's
just it's it's flashing that light and
it's it's trying to see
how much of that light is reflected and
how much is absorbed
by
your by you by your arm or whatever but
what it's really paying attention to
is the flow of blood
under
uh
um in in your veins and so on underneath
um
uh underneath that sensor
and so what is it doing well for example
it can measure heart rate by the fact
that
when there's every heartbeat you're
pushing oxygenated blood uh through
arteries and so on and the oxygenated
blood is a slightly different color than
the unoxygenated blood and so when that
that light
uh there's slightly more light absorbed
reflected whatever um and you can detect
the fact that there's a a slightly
different you're a slightly different
color every time your heart beats you're
very you know just for that second or
whatever it is you're a slightly
different color there's even um apps
where you can just look with a camera
image and you can figure out what
somebody's heart rate is by just looking
at a fast kind of movie of that person
and just seeing you know oh every movie
frame is a slight change of the color of
the person it gets slightly redder or
something every time the oxygenated
blood is pumped through in one heartbeat
so that's a so-called ppg sensor that
measures heart rate um and
it also can measure the amount of oxygen
in your blood that's how pulse oximeter
works for example it's measuring
essentially the color of the blood and
therefore thereby measuring how much
oxygen has been captured by the
hemoglobin in your red blood cells
so those are cases where you're
measuring something just from the
outside just from flashing a light
outside and measuring what comes back
you're measuring something about the the
chemicals effectively in the blood
but the thing that's been kind of a goal
for a long time in medical sensors is to
have something where you can
measure not just let's say oxygen level
but the levels of let's say a million
different chemicals and a million
different kinds of things in your blood
and
uh there are some approaches to doing
that they've never quite been made to
work
but probably they eventually will be the
most prominent is when you shine a laser
or you have some light a photon of light
hits a molecule
it makes the molecule kind of jiggle
around and kind of there there's some
energy of pumping energy into a molecule
and so the molecule will kind of flap
around and the molecules kind of like it
has a bunch of atoms that are at least
roughly it's as if they had all those
atoms attached by springs and so when
the photon hits the molecule you're kind
of uh you know you're kind of kicking
that assembly of atoms with springs
together and the molecule will kind of
blob around
and the molecule depending on the shape
of the molecule that blobbing around
will have a characteristically different
set of frequencies associated with it so
there might be some piece that is that's
sort of a heavy piece connected to a
light piece here by this bridge and the
bridge will always sort of flop around
in this particular way
so there's a there's an
approach to seeing kind of how the laser
light is absorbed and reflected that
basically gives you information about
all that kind of vibration of the
molecule
and depending on the frequency of
vibration different things will happen
with that laser light
particularly as a phenomenon called
roman spectroscopy where you get to kind
of see the spectrum
of kind of vibrations of the molecule
now if one could make that work kind of
through the skin
etc one could have a little watch or
something that would immediately give on
a readout of the levels of all these
different kinds of chemicals so probably
you know every time you eat the glucose
level and your blood will go up because
you're ingesting that sugar and there
are continuous glucose monitors that
people with diabetes use um which have
little catheter that sticks underneath
the skin and is measuring
the uh the amount of glucose in not
quite in a blood vessel but in kind of
the the space near blood vessels and so
but that's the kind of thing where in
principle if one could make this kind of
uh
light based approach
one could have something where you don't
have to stick anything under your skin
you can just from the outside measure
the level not just of glucose but of
lots of other kinds of things and again
if we did that we'd see all kinds of
stuff go up and down you know we'd see
glucose every time we eat it will go up
we'd see things like uh human growth
hormone secreted at night we'd see
just all kinds of different things going
through the day different kinds of of
hormones and chemicals secreted at
different times some of our glands that
secrete those things release you know
they kind of build up for a day and then
they suddenly release things we see all
kinds of things like that and we
progressively see different kinds of
things that represent potential problems
building up in our bodies we'd see those
potentially progressively building up
and that
technology doesn't exist yet but i think
it eventually will and that will be a
different kind of way that we can help
to sort of uh
make it easier to to make the right
medical intervention i mean in general
with medicine there's sort of a funny
principle which is you know if
something's wrong with you it will
either get better or get worse and
in a sense what happens is there's
something where you say well you know
my finger hurts slightly
um
but uh and then you know
and then it either will get worse and if
it gets worse it will usually localize
to oh there's a particular thing or
you'll figure out there's a particular
thing that's causing that to happen or
it will get better in which case the
typical approach is why worry about it
it's better so let's just go on and uh
uh declare victory sometimes it's a good
thing to try and go back and see can we
tell what actually happened it's
certainly true in the case of software
when errors just sort of seem to go away
it's it's really a good thing
particularly if you're interested in
making the software as good as possible
to say well what actually happened why
did it go wrong in the first place even
though well it seemed to have fixed
itself
um but uh you know i think that one of
the one of the real approaches to
improving medicine is better sort of uh
early warning of things now you know
it's sometimes a challenge because there
may be a huge amount of data involved in
that early warning and having good ways
to process that is its own separate
issue anyway we could yack on about that
for ages but um that was an attempt to
to answer that that question
um
let's see
aaron asks
talking about our multi-computation
paradigm
an approach to medicine based on that
will detect disease first by observing
visual systems or chemical systems or
otherwise
you know i think
as a question
of what can one detect about what's
going on
in us
biochemically
and
part of what that depends on is what
matters biochemically
what matters to the operation of us as
sort of molecular machines
and you might say all that matters is
the concentration of this or that
chemical you know how much of this do we
have how many molecules are of this type
rather than some other type but it might
also be that there's some much more
detailed pattern
of this molecule tends to collide with
that molecule that gets stuck on this
membrane that does this that gets
transported along some fiber in each
cell and so on that it isn't really
quite the story of just how much of each
chemical is there see for example in
something like a liquid
the molecules in a liquid are all
jiggling around and so when chemical
reactions occur where if there are
molecules that can react to it with each
other that can can when they collide
they'll turn into a different kind of
molecule for example in a liquid you
might assume that these molecules are so
randomly bouncing around it's randomly
mixed and eventually depending on how
many molecules there are that's the only
thing that would determine how long it
would take on average for two molecules
to to collide and react
but if it isn't a liquid if it's really
something where there are all these
tubes that are moving things around and
they're these membranes that things are
connecting to or even within the liquid
that you can look at individual
molecules that were produced and then
they were sort of
around in the same area and then they
interact with that same molecule again
and so on that the details of the sort
of at the molecular scale of what's
happening of the the story of the
molecules of what happened what was the
sequence of events that happened to this
molecule and so on that may be important
in molecular biology in biochemistry it
isn't known yet um it's something which
i suspect may be very important
if that's the case it could be that we
will be able to learn a spectacular
amount about how our molecular biology
is operating by measuring these some of
these kinds of things about the kind of
dance of individual molecules rather
than what we're doing right now which is
to measure these things like these roman
spectroscopy i was just talking about
are measuring total amounts of different
kinds of chemicals in us and it may be
that what really matters much more is
much more of this kind of sequence of
events that take place among molecules
and that requires a completely new kind
of sensor which yes i've been thinking
about how you would make such a sensor
but i don't yet know so yes it could be
that once we have those kinds of sensors
it'll be like oh my gosh we can see all
these new things that are really
important for the operational molecular
biology
and where we can make a kind of an early
warning of oh something is going wrong
in this particular pathway of this
particular sequence of molecules that
are getting produced
uh
well there's a there's a question
there's something
comes up here
um
uh it's a question about mortality
curves and survivor survival functions
um
yes there's a there's a bunch of math
there's a nice
handling of this in awesome language of
survival curves mortality curves and so
on actually wolfman alpha has this as
well um you can see all this um
um
uh
all this kind of um
um
you can see all these kinds of functions
what's the probability of dying in each
successive year what's the average time
that people live to
what's the um you know all these
different distributions and and you can
see those in with malfoy for example
from standard data um you know the the
that data i mean i you know there's kind
of a
um
a grim thing in the u.s it's called the
death index
um and it's a public database
of um
uh information about
uh all all deaths
and so that data allows one to to get
pretty accurate mortality curves
of what the lifespan is how long etc etc
um so but but then there's a bunch of
math to do with um
and you can get it it's it's tricky
because it's like
for example
um
what is it called
um uh
dailies d-a-l-y-s um
oh my gosh i think it's
disability-adjusted life years
but there's a question of if you ask a
question like
um
actually that that's that's not so
relevant there are all these questions
about
um
people
who were
uh who got this kind of drug
lived on average an extra 10 years let's
say
but
it's very tricky sometimes to work that
out because the people
might be 95 years old when they get the
drug and so they're likely to die from
other causes having nothing to do with
the effect of the drug and so so
untangling all of that stuff relates to
this whole
survival curves and so on as i say
wolverine language has a nice subsystem
for handling those kinds of things
that's integrated with lots of other
capabilities
the same kind of thing occurs with
reliability curves
for reliability analysis for
uh devices out there in the world i mean
you know light bulbs for example
typical light bulb a little bit like
human lifespan it typically lasts for a
pretty long time it's just fine and then
over a short period of time it tends to
have a a you know it lives it's it's not
80 years but it's it's some amount of
time and then the probability of it
failing goes up pretty rapidly uh at the
end of its kind of natural span
um and different kinds of systems have
different kinds of survival curves and
different mechanical systems etc have
different kinds of survival curves and
the the um
uh the
a common thing not for humans but it's
quoted for mechanical devices is mtbf
mean time between failures
so for example if you have
something like i don't know
a computer and you say what's its mean
time between failures you might say well
on average this computer will run for 20
years without failure
any particular computer might fail
earlier than that but that's the average
time
um and so there's there's lots of
interesting math around around how that
works
uh
question comment here from jr would
there be any justification for pursuing
eternal life for humans if feasible
um
you know that's a complicated question
of ethics i kind of think that
uh i think the answer is yes but but
then you know
i'm here and exists and alive and i i
have a good time and it's like i'd like
to continue as long as possible
um
is it something where
it would be uh you know sort of
societally disastrous what's a
complicated story
because you might think
so you know one big advantage is
that people who've been around longer
know more
and maybe
can
figure out better what to do you know
you probably don't want
a um
you know i i don't know whether you want
a 15 year old um
sort of uh
running the decision to um
whether to make some uh sort of uh you
know whether to um launch some military
attack or something like this i
certainly this has happened in history
that um it's been up to the 15 year olds
um and uh you know some have been like
alexander greater than how old he was
when he started conquering the known
world but he wasn't he wasn't terribly
old um and uh
you know
well he certainly did well whether the
people
that he um conquered did well is is a
whole different question
but um uh you know i think that there
are things where
uh the you know the longer people have
been around the more likely they are to
not do crazy things
now on the other hand uh there tends to
be a situation where people who said
i've been doing this all my life it's a
great way to do it i'm never gonna
change
and so there are things where
people you know if lifespans get longer
there's a certain degree of we're not
gonna change anything
now it could be that everything's great
and there's no reason to change and the
change is bad but it could be that at
least some people think things aren't
great and they need to be changed and so
then it's a complicated trade-off about
kind of the the um uh the the general
tendency of people have been around
longer to say
things shouldn't change and the general
tendency of younger people to say
hey we could change anything we want
um and that kind of uh equilibrium that
though and not necessarily equilibrium
that tension
is something which could be a good thing
could be a bad thing so i think it's
it's a complicated
discussion but i i tend to think
that
uh you know it's it's obviously
um you know death is the single greatest
destroyer of information and knowledge
um i mean it's kind of like people learn
stuff and some of it they can pass on
in you know the things they write the
live streams they do whatever else it is
but a lot of it is kind of locked into
that brain
and um it's something where um uh
it's some
um
uh the um
uh
you know when the brain dies you just
lose that knowledge and you use lose
that that skill and so on and so on and
and that's the thing where as we
gradually you know in our civilization
the thing that's really happened is that
we have been gradually accumulating
knowledge and we've been doing that
partly through sort of the the teaching
the the older uh crowd teaches the
younger crowd and that places our
knowledge and partly through uh sort of
external media of books live streams
programs whatever else it is
um but uh so so those are but you know i
i uh perhaps it's just a personal
preference but i have to say i think um
i think human immortality would be would
be pretty cool i think you know for
somebody like me who's got an almost
infinite number of projects that i'd
like to do the longer i have to do it
the better now i have to say the flip
side of that is if you say well i
imagine i'll live for a thousand years
or ten thousand years or a million years
it's like why would i do anything today
there's no kind of sense of urgency and
i think it will be the case that when
lifespans extend or perhaps there's
there's effective immortality that it
does affect motivation because it's kind
of like you know i want to do the stuff
because i want to do it while i can
still do it as opposed to well i get
around to it sometime
you know that that thing i was planning
to figure out you know what sometime the
next 100 years i'm going to do it maybe
um and so you know i think that the way
that it will affect human motivation is
kind of complicated i think that
uh one of the things that has been a
change
is this idea of whether people sort of
do only one thing in their lives they
have one career and they say this is
what i'm going to do
and that's my thing for my for my life
so to speak whether one expects more
people to say well i'm going to do this
for 30 years then i'm going to do this
for another 30 years
in the past when the length of a career
was somewhat shorter
um it was like you're really not going
to get you know it typically when you
get into doing something in a first
approximation it takes a decade to
become an expert in doing something and
you know there aren't that many decades
that fit in a short human lifespan and
so if you're going to become do
something which you've got expert at
doing it's kind of like uh you can't
switch that around too many times but as
if lifespans get much longer then you
can become an expert in a whole sequence
of things and get to make use of that
time um as opposed to saying look you
know i've only got 30 years to do all
these things and um you know i by the
time i've invested 10 years in becoming
an expert i'd better have 20 years to
actually use that expertise um and you
know that's kind of a an approach to
that
um
let's see i just a couple more things
here maybe i'll stick on this topic of
um
uh of kind of medicine and
and so on here
um
let's see
well wobin comments that aging might be
the condition that makes the most sense
to study economically in terms of the
money spell by health systems on
problems related to it yeah well for
sure
i mean
that's why it's so weird that there's
this kind of bureaucratic glitch
because the fact is sort of the optimal
thing in a sense
is
uh you know given that there's only a
finite lifespan the best thing is for
people to be super healthy
until maybe the end of their lives and
the worst thing is they just get more
and more unhealthy and they can kind of
you know be there's more and more
medical stuff that has to be done and
it's very expensive to do all those
things
by the way i mean it's worth realizing
that
uh you know what's expensive and what's
not is a complicated issue
you know for example
one of the things that's sort of a big
surprise in a sense in the world last 50
years or so is that consumer electronics
is cheap
that is you know when i was first using
computers i used computers that were
really expensive i mean computer i use
for a while cost
well in those days probably quarter
million dollars probably today it would
be half a million a million dollars
and you know it was kind of a luxury
computer that was very expensive
and but now the computers that i use are
pretty much
consumer computers that many people can
afford and you know computers are
fundamentally cheap it's fundamentally
cheap to make microprocessors it's
fundamentally cheap to make uh
telecommunications equipment these kinds
of things
by by making it in such large numbers
and there's nothing sort of
intrinsically expensive about it once
you have the equipment to make it you
can just churn out more and more and
more uh microprocessors for example and
each one is not terribly expensive
so the question is when it comes to
things in medicine for example there's
this fact that there's things for
whatever reason a lot of medicine is
quite expensive
and it's not clear it has to be that way
it could be the case so for example with
drugs
often actually making the drug is not
expensive what's expensive is doing all
the research and development to figure
out what drug to make and doing all the
tests on the drug and getting it
approved and all these kinds of things
that cost might cost a billion dollars
and by the time that's cost a billion
dollars you've got to you know get back
some of what you spent by actually
selling that drug to people
but it might be that the incremental
cost of making the drug is really very
very low
and
that you know with a different kind of
economic system you would end up with
something where yes you know everybody
can have that particular thing it might
be the case you know if there are i
don't know nanobots that we can inject
into ourselves that go and uh serve as
an artificial immune system or something
that it might be actually very cheap to
produce those things but it might have a
huge health benefit for people
um and i think that's sort of a it's an
interesting issue
whether the important
things for for health and medicine are
expensive
i mean it uh
you know certain kinds of surgery for
example they require a lot of human
skill they require lots of people
involved they require lots of facilities
and so on but maybe you know maybe
there's something where you just send in
the bot army and it goes and assembles
in the right place and it's all just a
simple control mechanism and so on and
it doesn't cost very much
and you know i think sometimes
you know i tend to think anecdotally
particularly in the us i don't know in
all other countries that the amount of
kind of bureaucratic inefficiency in the
medical system is just spectacularly
large
and
why that inefficiency exists is
complicated and i think that you know
probably
you know this question of does medicine
have to be expensive
and or could it be the case that
you know it might be that medicine can't
help you there's nothing known to solve
that particular medical problem but it
could be that if there's a solution
then it is comparatively cheap to get
that solution just as if there's
something i can compute on a computer
it's fundamentally fairly cheap to get
the computer and do that computation so
we just don't know how that's going to
go for medicine i have to say i think
that my own guess is that as more of
medicine ends up being about molecular
scale uh machines and about essentially
software that it probably will drive
down the
cost curves in the same way as that's
happened with consumer electronics
um the uh
okay so
uh there's comments here about uploading
uh
human
sort of consciousness into computers and
that as a as a mechanism for effective
immortality
um
the
that's a complicated issue
uh you know i think that
uh it's kind of like
if
one is
sort of able to
sort of run the same computations as a
running in our brains you know in some
sense the soul of a human
in in some uh sort of uh
there is is this pattern of um of
computations that are happening in our
brains that's kind of the the the
abstract one could even say sort of uh
uh immortal
version of kind of um uh human existence
is that kind of abstract pattern of
computations that's running in our
brains
and where our memories are stored in the
case of our brains our memories are
stored in the particular details of our
nerve cells
some controversy actually about exactly
how memories are stored in in nerve
cells but but they're stored somehow in
nerve cells
and you know imagine you could upload
all of that stuff so it's just stored in
computers
and then
could
we could have sort of the experience the
same experience that we have with brains
we could have through that uploaded
consciousness and computers and and
probably that could work
um
i think
that uh there's sort of a question of
what's it going to be like
to live in this kind of uploaded
you know you could call it metaverse
type
environment
and uh and how's that going to how's
that going to go
you know it's complicated it's hard to
know i mean a lot of the issues that we
have in human society
they will be different in uploaded
society so to speak
so for example the very idea that we're
all mortal so to speak we have only a
limited number of years and what are we
going to do with that time and that's a
driver for saying i want to do stuff
or i can't be bothered i'm just going to
live out my life because it's only a
finite amount of time i it's okay i'm
not going to be bored i'm only going to
be bored for for a limited time i'm not
going to be bored for a million years
um
so and that's different if you are in a
situation where there's effective
immortality there's also a bunch of
issues with uh clone with with kind of
copying you've got one version of a
human mind you say well i'm just gonna
make a copy of that human mind you know
there's there's me
and there's copy one two three four five
of me and it's like what would you
you know how would you enjoy interacting
with yourself
i don't know it's um uh you know it's an
interesting thing people who are
identical twins might have had a little
bit of experience like that
but
it's a it's sort of a question of what
would it be like if there's a hundred of
you and you hang out with lots of copies
of you is that good is that bad but
those are different dynamics
of sort of society and you know 100
copies of you that all shared the same
memories up to now
and then have started to diverge what's
that going to be like there are lots of
lots of kinds of things that were very
different
and when it comes to you know is there a
top dog
in
sort of in the virtual environment
and you know the top dog might be the
one who's accumulated
the largest amount of you know land
money this that or the other um and
how's that going to play out when all of
that stuff
is kind of um
uh very virtualized so to speak
and uh and you know what's that kind of
existence gonna be like and i think one
of the things that is
potentially
a from looked at from our vantage point
today
the kind of you know the uploaded humans
kind of playing video games for the rest
of eternity looks like a pretty bad
outcome looks like gosh that sounds
really boring
but i have the feeling that once you're
embedded in that process
it will seem as meaningful as the things
we do today see
i mean you know the sort of thought
experiments go back a thousand years and
say
what
um what would what are the things that
seemed meaningful a thousand years ago
and look at the things we do today and
would we even understand from a thousand
years ago why are we doing some of the
things we're doing today they don't seem
meaningful and as we project forward and
we're in the you know the virtual world
metaverse type thing and we're doing all
these weird things where we're kind of
you know playing
games where we clone ourselves and
virtually clone ourselves and then we
take the clone and we do i don't know
we compete with the clone who's
identical to us and we see this and we
see that it's like why are you doing
this we can't understand that from our
vantage point today but once one's
embedded in that environment it may seem
like the most meaningful thing one can
imagine and you know it's like saying
what is the ultimate meaning of what we
do
and there isn't really an ultimate
meaning to it it's something where we
have become used to a certain pattern of
what we think is important and no doubt
that will evolve if we're in a different
kind of situation and if we're sort of
all uploaded to conscious uploaded you
know minds i have this kind of image
that i've talked about in the past of
the the box of a trillion souls
of um of sort of the future of humanity
and what that means
um
the question here
uh
let's see where where um was asked if
you could live for 150 years but you had
to upload your brain to this metaverse
and give up your whole body
would you upload your brain in that
situation
um
boy these are these are complicated
questions because
it's kind of like
um
you know if that's where the action is
that's where everybody's in the uploaded
world
it's kind of like if if you're
interested in hanging out with the
humans well that's where you hang out
with the humans and you could be the
sole
survivor of the um you know the embodied
human
and all
all the fun stuff is going on in the box
of a trillion souls so to speak um or a
different situation i i think it's a uh
i think it's
i think what will tend to be the case
is that gradual things
will be the things that
feel most natural that is it the sort of
the sudden change from this to that
will
be very disorienting and if there's a
sort of gradual change from oh yeah you
gradually replace more parts of your
body with with uh
you know technology and so on you
gradually replace small parts of your
brain you're gradually plugging into
different parts of your brain and
you know i just saw a new invention that
is is capable of of sending signals to
the brain by by running essentially
electrode arrays through
through uh um
through through catheters through blood
vessels um which means you don't have to
like open up the brain to be able to to
put electrodes to probe different parts
of the brain or to send signals to
different parts of the brain and you
know one can imagine all kinds of ways
in which so one's gradually uh going
towards having more of your brain as
being sort of outsourced to technology
and that feels like a more natural kind
of progression of you know oh i'm you
know like for me i have uh
all my sort of data from the last 30
years or more and and beyond uh kind of
nicely digitally encoded so i can do
searches for things and all that kind of
thing but right now i'm doing that by
typing with my fingers and looking at a
screen and seeing what the results are i
could imagine a situation where in
addition to my own human memory i have
sort of immediate digital access to this
much larger bank of memory or for
example if i wanted to do a mathematical
computation you know if i was directly
connected to wolfram language and
mathematica and so on and i just had to
think the computation and it would
magically the answer will be delivered
into my brain rather than me having to
type with my fingers and look at the
answer um it would be that would be sort
of a progression towards something where
more of my brain is is outsourced to
technology and for example
some of that technology might say
god might have suggestions you know hey
you've been yakking on about this or
that thing what about mentioning this
or you know here's something you said
about that before or you know here's a
thing you know this or that thing and
that begins to become much more
entangled with your actual uh you know
decisions about what you do you know
it's like
you know you really don't want to eat
that thing that looks kind of uh looks
kind of tasty in front of you you know
you already ate far too much today type
thing and pretty soon you're outsourcing
more and more of your sort of thinking
process
to uh to the digital uh area
um
okay there's one
last
comment here let's see
um
paul comments uploading a copy of your
brain into a computer means there are
two of you and computational
irreducibility means the two are
different from each other yeah yeah well
it's certainly the case that as soon as
the brain the uploaded brain starts
operating with its different environment
it will do different things and it will
learn different things from what we
biologically with you know walking
around with our eyes you know five foot
something off the ground kind of um uh
kind of perceive of the universe
and yes the you know when if you make
100 clones of yourself and they're all
having different experiences they will
be different they'll sort of become
different over time it's like and this
is kind of the ultimate nature versus
nurture question you know are we
determined by our nature by the genetics
that we have and and all those kinds of
things i mean what we eat where those
kinds of things are or perhaps
or more more so by the sort of intrinsic
genetics that we have or are we
determined by the nurture the
experiences that we have and that's sort
of the ultimate version of that when you
make the hundred clones of yourself um
you know in in this virtual clones of
yourself what happens to each of those
and and how much are they affected by
the by the nurture of their experience
so to speak rather than by the initial
condition that they have
um
william is asking is bureaucratic
inefficiency analogous to aging and
biological systems the system over time
grinds to hold and dies due to a buildup
of systematic inefficiencies can we
apply life extension to institutions
that's an interesting question
you know i tend to think
uh bureaucracy is like viscosity and
friction
it's like it could be the case
that
uh
the world would immediately decide you
know
uh let's do this or that thing you know
immediately it's like um
oh i don't know
uh this kind of um
this person is bad this um
this thing you know we should uh
um
you know put a new traffic light on this
road whatever else it is or we should um
uh change what we teach about this or
that in this way but the way the world
actually works it adds a certain
viscosity it adds a certain sort of slow
flow so it adds a certain sort of
friction to things to have bureaucracy
it's like oh well you have to file that
form and triplicates and you have to
wait for this approval to happen and
that to happen and so on and that all
takes a month
and so that
that that rapid decision of let's just
do this
it's like no it actually is going to
take a month because this and that and
the other thing needs to be done
now that's all good if you're trying to
prevent crazy things from happening in
the world it's bad if you're trying to
allow new things to happen in the world
because that same viscosity that kind of
prevents the crazy quick things
happening also makes it really difficult
to take that new thing that you really
did want to change and sort of move it
out of that area of just this very
viscous kind of um you know you can't
get there from here there's there's uh
there's a thousand forms you have to
fill out to get from here to there
so i think it is the case that over time
uh large
institutional structures build up more
and more bureaucracy i know in in
our own company my own company
um
it's been kind of amusing to me over the
last 35 years we've gradually built up
different kinds of sort of bureaucracy
and and occasionally yes you have to go
in and cut out the bureaucracy i
remember years ago now
what um
uh
we discovered that there was a 14-step
procedure for getting business cards and
you know what did that involve well it
involved you know how many cards do you
want is the title that you're being
given on the cards the right thing
did you get your you know do you like
the configuration of your name on the
business card you know where the
business cards are gonna be shipped to i
don't know i don't know what all the
steps were but
you know eventually you realize that's
just crazy that's just taking all this
effort and you know the thing that gets
bad
is when
kind of the bureaucracy is taking all
the effort let me give you an example in
a computer when the computer is running
different programs one of the components
of the operating system with your
computer is a scheduler which says you
know right now you should run this
program you should be running your video
conferencing program or or now oh no
that doesn't need to run anymore you
should be running the program that's
doing your chat session whatever and
that scheduler is making decisions about
what to run when
so one thing that happened years ago in
a one of the common operating systems is
that people tried to add more and more
cleverness to the scheduler until
eventually it was taking 70 percent of
the time that the computer had to just
decide what to do next and only 30
percent of the time is spent actually
doing anything
and so that's something that can happen
when you sort of over over build the
kind of the structure around doing
things the same thing happens in
countries and with governments and so on
that eventually the government gets so
heavyweight that you know half the
people in the country are working for
the government sort of enabling the
things that could actually happen to
actually do things
so i think this process of um
uh sort of the the tendency to increase
bureaucracy
as the system gets more and more you
know another reason why bureaucracy
increases is something went wrong
and so you say let's add in
this new check to make sure that doesn't
go wrong again and pretty soon you've
added all these checks and you've built
this giant bureaucracy um so that uh um
that that makes things run much more
slowly and makes it much more difficult
to make changes
so
it's an interesting question whether one
could apply
kind of uh
um
the sort of
life extension i i would say that
that
bureaucracies rarely grind completely to
a halt it's usually the case that
even though you know there's now a
two-year wait to get this or that
government approval for something it
does eventually happen
it isn't the case now
you know you can have bureaucracies
where
effectively things die trying as they
try and grind through the bureaucracy
and lots of things that you want to have
happen never happen for that reason but
i don't think it's quite as dramatic
um it can be kind of the i suppose it's
the question of do you lead the healthy
life
um you know you're you're alive but
you're not very healthy and that can be
the situation where bureaucracies are
too deep and too too kind of
viscous
and then the question is how do you
simplify those things and that's what oh
all kinds of different um
it takes real effort it takes real
leadership
to to simplify these things and i know
in our company for example you know i
will occasionally try and hack out a
piece of bureaucracy where it's like
well there are all these steps and all
these things but now we understand it
better i'll give you an example um so
one of the things i noticed is in when
you're shipping things
years ago
uh like the air bills that you use to
ship something by fedex or whatever else
when fedex was young the bills were very
simple
as fedex got a little older the air
builds got more and more and more
complicated they get more and more
details on them of you know check the
box if you're shipping live live
specimens or check the box if you're
doing this it got more and more
complicated
and then
somebody must have gone in and said this
is way too complicated let's simplify it
again and it got much simpler and it had
sort of i don't know how they've dealt
with all these sort of special cases but
it's like if any of these are true check
this box and you have to fill out a
different form but most of the time you
don't have to do that it's the same with
user experience design you know you can
end up with something where oh you've
got to this screen there are a hundred
things you might do from this screen and
in principle if you present all those
hundred things which gradually
originally there were five things but
then over time more and more things got
added as things you might do
and then you have a hundred things on
the screen it's like i can't find
anything anymore and so then you have to
go back and say well what can we do to
simplify this can we make something
where you can
sort of get the most essential things
and have kind of an escape valve to deal
with the more complicated cases and
that's part of the sort of the design of
user experience but but i would say this
sort of retrofitting of simplified user
experience the the removal bureaucracy
removal yeah it kind of reminds me of of
the removal of senescent cells uh aged
cells in in biological organisms but i
haven't really thought about whether
sort of the ideas of most of the ideas
for life extension are fairly specific
to the way that humans and our
biological medical systems work so i'm
not sure those are applicable but kind
of the general notion that even while
it's running you might do things to
simplify the sort of bureaucratic load
um yes that's a that's an interesting
thing to think about and something where
you could say well can we do this you
know or is it locked in do we have this
sort of constitution that locks in this
giant bureaucracy or do we have kind of
the wiggle room
to say well we're going to change this
and simplify the things so that we can
allow the system to be more agile so to
speak
all right well lots of interesting
questions here and more i can see saved
up for next time
and i look forward to seeing you um
in another
live stream i think we'll be doing um on
wednesday we'll be doing i'm not sure
what what phase we're in it's either
history of science and technology or q a
about business innovation and managing
life that's why one of the other of
those and the next friday i'll be doing
another one of these science and
technology q a's okay apparently um this
next week will be a history of science
and technology q a on wednesday
um
and uh we're also doing
uh i'm also doing some other live
streaming of other
uh
uh internal meetings and uh you know
check out the um
the what it's actually like to build
software and so on and what my day job
is
um if you're interested in in other live
streams that we'll be doing
but okay let's wrap up here for now
thanks for joining me